I think this is a really good place to
leap off and do our next thing okay
which is you asked me what happens when
we swap these two let's swap that around
okay I would sure look at this again so
now I'll make a new subheading okay I'm
going to give it a name in a second but
I want to look at what the mass is first
you took these two right by the way
they're called variables let's just
label those you took the variables that
you swap them and then you got this
shape well there's something else you
can swap here as well actually a few
different things the thing we're
particularly looking at this morning is
see these guys on the right hand side x
+ 2 x squared what happens when you swap
those y equals not X ^ ^ X now this is
this is interesting because it looks
well the numbers look different to what
we've gone over here right they've
rearranged differently okay but actually
we've looked at these things before we
did a whole topic on them underneath
algebra right when you've got things up
here in the power we called these
indices do you remember that um few
weeks it was called an index power there
was one more name it had the most
unusual name that's uncommon one but I
taught it to you back there
it starts with an E I told you back then
specifically so that this title would
make sense does anyone remember what the
name was for see the problem is we
almost never use it for
it's true and the reason why it's useful
to know they had cold experiences
because these graphs are called
exponential right now we've actually
even if you don't use know much about
the matter which we can explore a second
right we actually use this language
we're using all the time we chase
something grows exponentially which
means is that slow or fast that's fast
it's really really fast okay it means it
doesn't just grow but it grows faster as
time goes on it gets steeper and steeper
steeper stable so here's my question um
just like if you've got a piece of sheet
music and you said okay well I guess if
I could read this then I can I can play
it and see what it sounds like right
I'll hear what it sounds like what does
this look like we know what all of these
look like there is a button on your
calculator we have a TOEFL okay on what
things look like when we have no idea
any any information about though what
was that school that we keep going back
to over and over again you remember are
you gonna answer something you also this
question yeah well it is going to go
really hard but my question is how highs
are gonna go right and is there anything
you say do you remember this guy this is
a table value you take x and y values
right and then you try something you see
what happens okay now do you remember
with me up with the parabola what we did
was we went we tried out negative two
negative ones your one two yeah we
tested out numbers we saw what happened
well we tried these out I'll just
refresh your memory we got these numbers
four one zero one four right you know we
said oh it's like a it's like a
palindrome it's like it's it's mirrored
right and that's why these shapes are
mirrored okay well let's see what
happens with these guys in fact
two three four five six let's have let's
try these guys let's give them a go in
order to get an accurate picture of this
okay you need to remember how indices
want remember the C's the spiral power
is exposed they're all the same thing
so let's just do a few numbers first do
you remember our let's go with a simple
example
something like say three squared through
the power of two what does that mean
what's that short for it's an
abbreviation good three times three
which of course is nine no problem about
that down because it's trivial if I were
to say make it a bigger number of their
three to the power of five what's
actually I can't five times you get the
idea
okay good good good so therefore right
away just off of this straight away we
can fill out one two three values okay
this is y equals not three but two to
the power of these numbers here okay so
if X is 1 then this will be 2 to the
power of 1 to the power of 1 that's just
okay then 2 to the power of 2 will be 4
now careful to the power of 3 right
would mean hey I should do 2 times 2
times 2 again and that's 8 okay now have
it look at this right from here you can
kind of follow a pattern if you can't
remember this right look at these
numbers we went from left to right well
what if he went in the reverse order
here we from this to this what have we
done you've divided a device you have
Holland and that's exactly what I've
done 8 2 4 is hard 4 to 2 is also hard
so two should go to one when you have
two you get one
and then you should have again you
should call it again and then you should
have all again okay right now now notice
this with me please
we were just going from right to left
okay so you keep Bobbe
okay and so if I went from that's right
instead of hiring what's the opposite of
harvesting doubling it is it is adding
stock but more specifically
okay so first question how far do I go
until I hit like a maximum right till I
hit a point where I have to stop
anything does that mean infinite it
means I can keep on doing this there's
no limit to this well let's just think
about this I don't have to draw the
whole wrist of the table right what
would happen if you have this number if
you have to a quarter you get any what
would happen if you hard for that I'm
saying a 16 if you have it again okay
and you can start to see hold on in fact
just just look pay attention to these
denominators pay attention to them if I
went over this way you double eight you
get 16 and then you double that you
consented to in fact you're getting
exactly the same numbers here but there
this enumerator and these are
denominators right so these things are
all getting to smaller and these are all
getting bigger but if you can go in that
way forever you can also go this way
forever
okay now question how far would you have
to go to hit zero because these are
getting really small right if you put
this into your calculator it's a pretty
small number zero wait hold on never hit
zero are you sure these are getting now
you can pop this in your taco it's gonna
be zero point zero comma why it's a tiny
number
why not their superior on to something
why not
can we try it because this is really
important in maths you don't just say
okay that's the answer because all about
why is the answer what it is okay okay
that's true wait hold on a number
divided by two is never gonna be equal
to zero
so let's this picture this I guess it's
a little bit like you've got a cake
right
and then you slice it in half and then
you've got two halves right and then you
take Hobbes you slice that you know a
corner and you just keep on slicing
right now here's the thing with a cake
with a cake eventually eventually you
must stop you'll run out of cake
eventually it would just become like a a
mess on your plate right but this is
more than just K this is these numbers
right they really can't go forever
right and you will never you will never
ever get to zero you'll get some very
very small numbers okay but you'll never
reach that so therefore it follows the
same time see these numbers have they're
all positive rightness so how far would
I have to go to get a negative like can
I divide can I have a certain number of
times and get a negative no but
somewhere over you know for the same
reason that they can't get to zero right
no matter how many times you divide
you're never gonna get an anti cake
right you just get no cake so therefore
all these numbers are positive